une ferme biologique à plus grande
échelle voici une initiative qu'on pu
découvrir les délégations du projet
Guira une exploitation avec 250 vaches
et tout est 100% bio tout est basé sur
les produits naturels des animaux que
nous élevons nous-même nous utilisons
également le fumier produit par les
vaches comment Grey nous n'utilisons pas
de nourriture additionnelle les animaux
ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin ici
aujourd'hui l'agriculteur travaille avec
des grandes marques de distributeurs
allemands mais ils développent également
les circuits courts
nous avons testé de nombreux biais pour
vendre notre viande et la meilleure
façon de faire et d'avoir des contacts
directs directement avec les
consommateurs qui viennent ici pour
visiter la ferme et acheter la viande
pas de marine Berg se situe dans la
région de westerworld un grand massif
forestier la forêt est donc un enjeu
environnemental ma cette région est
couverte de petites villes et villages
les ressources principales sont le bois
et les richesses présentes dans le sol
alors ce sont les forêts et les sols qui
sont ici les principales sources de
revenus en raison du changement
climatique nous nous sommes rendus
compte que nous devions absolument
protéger ses forêts les établissements
scolaires s'emparent des questions
environnementales dans ce lycée
technologique les élèves participent à
des ateliers de sensibilisation et
construisent des projets autour du
développement durable et ils ont bien
expliqué ici que par exemple il recycle
plutôt que d'acheter du neuf et ils ont
beaucoup d'ateliers qui permettent
d'expliquer à ces étudiants que recycler
c'est mieux que d'acheter du neuf et je
pense que cette sensibilisation qu'il
donne à ses étudiants leur permettent de
bien comprendre les enjeux qu'il y a
dans le dans le développement durable et
dans éviter de jeter juste pour le
plaisir et de racheter du neuf les
réflexions du projet Guira se
poursuivront puisque les cinq
délégations européennes sont attendues
dans les Yvelines le 12 juin